[Música]
salud en directo américa france24 más
romeros hola por supuesto estar con
nosotros acompañándonos en este estudio
en esta mesa mar y volvemos a la
historia reciente reciente recién salida
del horno el inicio de la pandemia de
kobe 19 porque hay una nueva información
sobre cómo habría llegado el virus a
nosotros los humanos así es aunque nos
duela a veces tenemos que volver a ese
momento donde todas nuestras vidas
cambiaron para entender mejor cómo
sucedió y eso es lo que intentan hacer
dos estudios publicados en la revista
science podríamos decir que son dos
estudios hermanos publicados a la vez
uno intenta aclarar el dónde y el otro
intenta aclarar el cuándo vamos a
empezar por el primero por el tema
geográfico se hizo se hizo un mapeo muy
detallado de los primeros casos
registrados en diciembre de 2019 en la
ciudad china de wuhan y uno de los
hallazgos más sorprendentes de hecho es
que muchos de los casos de kobe 19 que
no tenían un vínculo directo con este
mercado que no se conocía que trabajaran
ahí que no se conocía que tuvieran
familiares o que hubieran ido ahí
recientemente también están agrupados
alrededor de este mercado de juana en el
mercado donde
desde hace tiempo que empezó el brote de
covite 19 de hecho además están más
cerca incluso en distancia media que los
casos que sí se conocen que tenían un
vínculo directo la media de los casos de
estos que tenían este vínculo conocido
era 5 más de 5 kilómetros mientras que
en diciembre ya muy al inicio de la
pandemia media de distancia de los casos
no conocidos con un vínculo no conocido
con el mercado era de 4 kilómetros eso
qué pistas nos da pues que probablemente
se estaba extendiendo el coronavirus de
manera sin pues sin rastrear se medida a
través de casos leves por ejemplo poco
sintomáticos sin que se hubiera sabido
vamos un poquito más adelante enero de
2020 febrero de 2020 que hicieron los
científicos cogieron datos de una
aplicación web o que puso una opción de
pedir asistencia médica por casos de
kobe en 19 de estos datos recogidos de
la aplicación lo que hicieron no fue
también de nuevo mapear los y qué
conclusiones tenemos que durante estos
dos primeros meses de brote de covite 19
seguía siendo el mercado de juanan uno
de los epicentros
de todo este brote de pandemia vemos ahí
como está marcado en este gráfico y como
el 50 por ciento aproximadamente de los
casos detectados seguían estando en esta
zona esto corrobora de nuevo con
bastante certeza esta hipótesis de que
este mercado fue el origen del brote del
cúbito 19 y pues realmente estos datos
geográficos hacen muy difícil pensar que
este brote se originará en cualquier
otro lugar claro marc también le quiero
preguntar teniendo en cuenta todo esto
si hay avances respecto a qué animal
digamos podría ser el portavo el
portador del virus pues digamos que
todavía no tanto este grupo de 'science'
fue muy concreto con los datos
geográficos llegaron incluso a
determinar cinco puestos dentro del
mercado en el sudeste del mercado su
este perdón del mercado de juanan que
podrían haber sido los lugares donde el
virus saltó de los animales a los
humanos y que se vendían ahí pues se
vendían varios animales por ejemplo el
perro mapache o mapache japonés también
tejones porcinos o zorros rojos entonces
digamos que todavía no se ha concluido
con con certeza con evidencia científica
exacta que éstos fueran los animales
pero digamos que la fiesta sobre cuál
podría haber sido el intermediario entre
por ejemplo los murciélagos o un animal
que tuviera reservorio de coronavirus
hasta los humanos pero sin embargo todo
esto sigue siendo a día de hoy todavía
una hipótesis pasamos ahora al origen
volvemos nuevamente en términos de
tiempo cuando se cree marc que hubo el
primer contagio humano es imposible
saberlo sí lo sabemos no sabemos con un
margen de error digamos porque se
hicieron unos estudios genómicos este es
el otro estudio como decíamos como
hermano de este primero que estábamos
hablando una de las principales
conclusiones es que este brote se dio
con dos sub variantes distintas dos
linajes distintos que pasaron y se
contagiaron a los humanos en dos eventos
distintos con aproximadamente una semana
de diferencia el linaje b fue el primero
y la fecha que preguntabas podría ser el
18 de noviembre de 2019 sin embargo como
decíamos hay un margen de error que va
desde finales de octubre hasta la
primera semana de diciembre y el linaje
a habría saltado de los animales a los
humanos del 25 de noviembre de nuevo con
un margen
relativo entre finales de octubre y
mediados de diciembre hay una cierta
paradoja porque el linaje a es el que se
parece más tienen menos mutaciones
respecto al que se cree que podría ser
el coronavirus abuelo del sars co2 que
se encuentra en los murciélagos entonces
parecía muy raro que fuera el que
segundo había llegado a los humanos sin
embargo es por eso que lo que lleva a
concluir que fueron dos eventos
distintos los que pasaron a los humanos
de ese evento de spielberg que se dice
en inglés algo bueno en este sentido es
que realmente podemos ver que entre la
fecha en que hubo este primer contagio
en los humanos y la fecha en que se
notificaron los primeros casos no pasó
tanto tiempo fueron unas semanas quedará
sin embargo la duda de si podríamos
haber aprovechado mejor esta rapidez en
detectar esta nueva enfermedad
cierra puerta este estudio
definitivamente la teoría del
laboratorio como origen de la pandemia
si una teoría que me gusta mucho exacto
y que bueno digamos que para al menos
tener pues el rigor científico
tendríamos que decir que todavía no
cierra la puerta definitiva porque nos
falta encontrar esa genealogía exacta de
los animales
sin embargo la aleja muy mucho la verdad
o sea hasta unas distancias que
podríamos empezar a decir que realmente
no es cierto que eso haya sucedido no es
el primer estudio que se publica
respecto al origen del comité 19 y cada
uno concluye ayuda a alejar como
decíamos esta teoría primero primero por
el tema geográfico como veíamos y luego
también por este tema de los dos linajes
es muy improbable que hubiera un
contagio dos tipos de contagios con dos
coronavirus linajes de coronavirus
distintos en un laboratorio o que se
intencionadamente liberarán dos linajes
distintos de coronavirus no es
importante decir pues todas estas
conclusiones todos estos nuevos datos
que van apareciendo para confirmar que
de nuevo esta teoría del laboratorio se
va alejando ahora va a tocar seguir
investigando de nuevo como decíamos en
esa genealogía particular y exacta y en
qué animales podrían haber sido pues los
que
terminaron contagiando a los humanos
pues muchísimas gracias como siempre por
toda la información de salud mañana con
más falsa más a saludar a nuestra
segunda invitada